[موسيقى]
هنا سوق مطرح اكثر المواقع حيويه في
العاصمه العمانيه مسقط الذي يعود تاريخه
لاكثر من 200 عام
[موسيقى]
هذا السوق شاهد حي على الاسواق الكلاسيكيه
في المنطقه حيث تتمثل بين اسقته ومحاله
الصور الاجتماعيه والمعالم العمرانيه
للسلطنه
بضائع متنوعه هنا في سوق مطرح التاريخي
باسعار مناسبه للغايه كما نشاهد هذا الشال
من القماش الكشميري الفاخر قيمته تقريبا
10 ريالات عماني اين يقارب ال 30 دولار
امريكي ايضا هناك بضائع اخرى متنوعه كما
نشاهد الهدايا التذكاريه التحف الالعاب
بالاضافه الى العطورات
واللبان العماني
[موسيقى]
جمال محمد علي يعمل في سوق مطرح منذ سنوات
ورث هذه التجاره من والده ويامل ان يستمر
ابنائه من بعده في هذا السوق حفاظا على
موروث العائله التجاريه
[موسيقى]
لما يطلعون من المدارس يكون ايام الاجازات
انه يجي لهم غرس الحب على الاعمال المحلات
التجاريه على الاسواق التقليديه
[موسيقى]
في هذا السوق التاريخي يستطيع الزائر ان
يستمتع بالمطاعم والمقاهي المنتشره حوله
لا سيما من امام ميناء مسقط التاريخي
[موسيقى]
سوق مطرح يقع في الجهه المقابله لميناء
السلطان قابوس الذي لطالم كان وجهه
الرئيسيه للقوافل التجاريه والبضائع
القادمه من الشرق والغرب ليكتسب من هذه
الادوار اسم مطرح بمعنى المكان الذي تطرح
فيه البضائع للزوار والمتفوقين
[موسيقى]